Sam a great start for you bidding one of
the tournament favorites player that
always says that he loves chess 9lx that
is Lavon aronian take us through this
game tell us how you approach this one
how did you prepare also for this
tournament uh I'm honestly mainly doing
tactics before the games because the
positions are so insane and have so many
complex patterns that it's hard to just
look at one position because all of them
are different how do you deal whenever
you see a pattern that you've never seen
in your life and finally it's something
completely different we've seen Ray on
the camera smiling sometimes when he's
missing a move or when he's finding a
fabulous move how do you react that yeah
I mean that's the beauty of this game
there's so many different ideas and when
you see something you haven't seen
before all you can do is just admire
what's happening on the board absolutely
and we've seen so many of those
situations take us through the first
game D4 Levon was saying that he had a
good position
yeah at one point this was very
interesting but probably Queen before
was in accuracy
that's funny that it's been played
online
versus Zoo Paris yeah I mean what I
misunderstood was after whatever he
plays in protect tonight then he plays
A5 next and basically either equalizer
just gets a nice position yeah so he
went for E5
uh long Castle B6 yeah
so here I'm just slightly worse
um
I was a bit happy that he went for this
end game because I mean even though it's
bad for white it's not that easy to win
yeah because my Knights on efforts trick
it's kind of like a blockade on the
king's side yes and then we got I think
it was somewhere around here after you
guys traded off once we got to this
position I mean I thought I have good
chances because
the knights are always very tricky yes
yes and it wasn't easy at all he only
had one particular moment I think it was
at this point when he could have played
uh C4 right here
but it wasn't easy like before Bishop H6
H6 and then
okay that's impossible with no times yes
yes and because you have to time it
right right right and he had like 14
seconds on it I mean uh objectively it's
probably good for black but with no time
it's hard to play with black because I
mean you move you move the bishop you
lose all the puns so were you playing
for a win right now are you content I
was definitely playing for a win for a
win yeah that's the mentality yeah right
and now he's just waiting for the king
to go to to the wrong Square to the
wrong Square yeah yes
and it did and yeah at this point King
to B6 King to C6
still shuffling the pieces
finally I went Knight before I took this
far yeah and King takes G3 are now B4
and now he has to move the king because
I'm pinned yeah yes King D7 or King to
B7 and then Bishop takes C3 and somehow
this position is still equal it's very
study like position
at this point he probably understood
that you're winning this will get back
in time
Sam congratulations uh good start for
you no losses up to this point how would
you assess your performance what's the
plan for tomorrow uh I mean through very
interesting positions and I think
through very fighting games but like all
of the games have been decided in the
blitz bullet portion of the game so at
the end of the day it's still rapid
chest and you have to be very sharp so
I'm just gonna try playing quick and
good moves I'm curious who did you team
up with and what do you guys usually do
what do you do for those 15 minutes in
between the position reveal and the
start of the game uh we have teamed up
with a lot of people I mean Ray Sam
Jeffrey and then Hikaru for the second
game so everyone has different styles
and different understanding of the game
so it's very interesting as well Sam
thank you very much we'll see you
tomorrow all right thank you quick
question for you Sam if you don't mind
uh just uh you're one of the youngest
players in the tournament and yet the
Iceman Cometh uh Gary Kasparov 60 year
old Gary Kasparov is leading the
tournament uh
you expected that
I mean it's pretty amazing I looked at
the standings I threw around to and I
saw his name at the top and I was like
okay he's he's informed for this one
very good thank you Sam good luck uh and
day two as the weekend comes up we'll be
playing three games tomorrow Saturday
three games tomorrow Sunday tell your
friends where you're hanging out as we
have
the guy